David Boder: [In English] Spool number 90 continued, Spool number 90 continued, at about fourteen minutes. The interviewee is Mr. Arthur Breslauer, fifty-four years old. The interview is taking place in the knitting shop, in the knitting training shop of the ORT in Geneva, August 28th 1946.
David Boder: [In German] Also wollen Sie, Herr Breslauer, uns nochmal Ihren vollen Namen geben, und sagen Sie uns wie alt Sie sind und wo sind Sie geboren?
Arthur Breslauer: Mein Name ist Arthur Breslauer, bin vier-, vierundfünfzig Jahre alt, bin in Ungarn geboren.
David Boder: Aha. Sagen Sie mal, Herr Breslauer, äh, wo hat Sie, erzählen Sie uns, wo Sie waren, wenn der Krieg angefangen hat, wo hat sie der Anfang des Krieges getroffen und was hat Ihnen nachher passiert?
Arthur Breslauer: Anfang des Krieges war ich in Budapest, wo ich seit fünfunddreißig Jahre lebte, und wo ich selbständiger Getreide- und Effekten-Händler war.
David Boder: Getreide- und was?
Arthur Breslauer: Effektenhändler.
David Boder: Ja. Wenn Sie nicht laut genug sprechen, dann wird diese Lampe hier und da “aufleiten”, nicht wahr? Das zeigt, dass Sie...äh, Getreide- und?
David Boder: Was heißt “Effektenhändler”?
Arthur Breslauer: [Pause] Wertpapierenhändler.
David Boder: Oh! Also Getreide und mit Wertpapieren.
Arthur Breslauer: An der Budapester Börse war ich fünfunddreißig Jahre tätig, davon fünfundzwanzig Jahre selbständig.
David Boder: Ja. Sie waren also ein Börsenmitglied.
Arthur Breslauer: Ja, Börsen-, Börsenkommissionär
David Boder: Sie waren ein Börsenkommissionär und haben Getreide auch auf Kommission und...
Arthur Breslauer: Auch auf Kommission
David Boder: Ver...
Arthur Breslauer: Teilweise auf Kommission, teilweise pro per....
David Boder: Also Sie waren in Ungarn geboren, lebten aber in Rumänien.
Arthur Breslauer: Nein, in Budapest.
David Boder: Ach, Bud...Entschuldigen Sie mal. Ich dachte Bukarest, sagten Sie.
Arthur Breslauer: Budapest. Die Hauptstadt von Ungarn.
David Boder: Budapest. Die Hauptstadt von Ungarn. Nun also, wo waren Sie, wenn der Krieg anfing?
Arthur Breslauer: Ich war zu Hause in Budapest. Und als die Deportation 1944 anfing und im sehr großen Maßen an der, in der Provinz stattfand...
David Boder: Ja.
Arthur Breslauer: Haben wir uns sehr gefährdet gefühlt und so sind wir mit der bekannten Gruppe von 1700 Seelen nach Deutschland, und zwar nach Bergen, Bergen-Belsen deportiert worden.
David Boder: Also, warten Sie mal. Das geht ein bisschen zu schnell. Wann sind die Deutschen nach Bukarest gekommen?
Arthur Breslauer: Nach Budapest!
David Boder: Nach Budapest gekommen?
Arthur Breslauer: Am 19. März 1944.
David Boder: Nun, was haben sie dann bekannt gemacht?
Arthur Breslauer: Die haben dann [unverständlich] beruhigt...die Juden, die Judenheit, die Judenschar
David Boder: Gesellschaft.
Arthur Breslauer: Die Gesellschaft, wenn sie noch nicht geschehen [Räuspern], ein jeder kann die jüdische Kulturalität üben...und wie sich herausgestellt hat, also, äh, diese Deklaration hat nur das Ziel gehabt, Un...Un..., keine, keine...[Pause], Unruhe...
David Boder: Keine Unruhe zu stiften.
Arthur Breslauer: Zu stiften und damit sie ihren Plan ungestört vollbringen können.
David Boder: Und was war dieser Plan?
Arthur Breslauer: Das Plan war, wie sich herausgestellt, die Vernichtung der Juden.
David Boder: Aha, nun.
Arthur Breslauer: Systematische Vernichtung.
David Boder: Ja.
Arthur Breslauer: Und als die Juden in der Provinz deportiert wurden, das heißt, es war im Zuge, und die Deportation schon nahe zu Budapest, und zwar in [Kispest?] [Der Ortsname ist unverständlich. Es könnte sich um Kispest handeln?] schon stattfand, haben wir uns entschlossen, zu dieser, äh, an, äh...zu dieser Gruppe uns...
David Boder: Welcher Gruppe?
Arthur Breslauer: Zu den 1700 Seelen...
David Boder: Was war das für eine Gruppe?
Arthur Breslauer: Da hat man eine sogenanntes Geschäft gemacht, mit den 1700 Seelen.
David Boder: Aha.
Arthur Breslauer: Man hat sie nach Deutschland geführt mit dem Versprechen, dass sie nachher so weiter geführt werden.
David Boder: Oh! Also es war, man hat eine Unterredung gemacht,...dass hier waren 1700 Seelen und die wollen nach Palästina gehen und man sollte [unverständlich]...
Arthur Breslauer: Man sagt uns Spanien.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Arthur Breslauer: Auf einem Umweg.
David Boder: Wie hat man das arrangiert? Wie ist das zustande gekommen?
Arthur Breslauer: Wir sind in einem Lager geführt, äh, beordert geworden.
David Boder: Nein, ich mein, wie ist es zustande gekommen, dass man überhaupt diese ganze Geschichte mit den Deutschen durchgesetzt hat?
Arthur Breslauer: Da war ein gewisser Dr. Kasztner. Der hat das veranstaltet. Und das war eine große, ein großzügige, großer Plan, der aber nur teilweise durchgeführt wurden, äh, wurde. Unsere Gruppe war eine sogenannte “Mustergruppe”.
David Boder: Ja.
Arthur Breslauer: Als Experiment.
Arthur Breslauer: Und da die Gefahr sehr gedroht hat, dass uns auch die Deportion, Dep—...Dep—...Deportation, also...
David Boder: Ja. Heimsuchen wird.
Arthur Breslauer: Heimsuchen wird, haben wir uns auf diese...
David Boder: Idee eingelassen.
Arthur Breslauer: Eingelassen. Ja, und zwar, es war alles sehr, sehr ungewiss, war.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Arthur Breslauer: Nun sind wir einwagoniert worden, und zwar von sechzig bis fünfundsiebzig Leute je ein Wagon und sind, sind, äh, etliche, elf Tage im Wagon gefahren.
David Boder: Ja.
Arthur Breslauer: Bis wir nach Bergen-Belsen angekommen sind.
Arthur Breslauer: Dort wurden die 1700 Seelen in zwei Baracken untergebracht.
David Boder: Ja.
Arthur Breslauer: Unter sehr schwierigen Verhältnissen.
Arthur Breslauer: Zusammengepfropft. Dort waren wir sechs Wochen. Während dieser sechs Wochen habe ich meine unvergessliche größere Tochter mit siebzehneinhalb Jahren verloren.
David Boder: Woran?
Arthur Breslauer: Sie ist gestorben.
David Boder: Woran ist sie gestorben?
Arthur Breslauer: An Lungenentzündung.
David Boder: Wo war das?
Arthur Breslauer: In Bergen-Belsen.
David Boder: Ja.
Arthur Breslauer: Es war grässlich, schauderhaft.
David Boder: Wie viele Leute waren im Ganzen in ihrer Familie?
Arthur Breslauer: Wir waren viere.
David Boder: Wer war das?
Arthur Breslauer: Meine Frau, Gymnasialprofessorin, Doktor der Mathematik.
David Boder: Ja.
Arthur Breslauer: Meine zwei Töchter.
Arthur Breslauer: Sehr gängige zwei Kinder.
David Boder: Wo ist die andere jetzt?
Arthur Breslauer: Die andere ist jetzt mit uns.
David Boder: Ja.
Arthur Breslauer: Besucht hier das Gymnasium.
Arthur Breslauer: Ist eine sehr begabte Person.
David Boder: Wie alt war sie, wenn Sie, äh, wenn Sie weggingen, wenn sie deportiert wurden?
Arthur Breslauer: Die kleine war elf Jahre.
David Boder: Ja.
Arthur Breslauer: Jetzt ist sie dreizehneinhalb.
David Boder: Also, wie lange hat die Reise von Budapest nach Belsen-Belsen [Boder wiederholt mehrmals falscherweise Belsen-Belsen, anstelle von Bergen-Belsen] gedauert?
Arthur Breslauer: Elf Tage.
David Boder: Was für einen Zug hatten Sie jetzt zur Ihrer Verfügung?
Arthur Breslauer: Viehwagon!
David Boder: Viehwagon!
Arthur Breslauer: Viehwagon. Ja.
David Boder: Und das war die “Mustergruppe”, nicht wahr?
Arthur Breslauer: Viehwagon.
David Boder: Waren Sie auch in diesem Wagon eingeschlossen?
Arthur Breslauer: Ja! Ja! Eingeschlossen waren wir nicht, also, das, äh,...die, die Türen waren offen .
David Boder: Ja.
Arthur Breslauer: Aber es war eine scheußliche Reise.
David Boder: Wieso?
Arthur Breslauer: In einem Wagon, wo normalerweise vierzig Leute unterbring, äh, untergebracht werden.
David Boder: Ja.
Arthur Breslauer: Dort waren wir sechzig, fünfundsiebzig Leute untergebracht.
David Boder: Männer, Frauen und Kinder?
Arthur Breslauer: Männer, Frauen, Kinder zusammen.
David Boder: War dort eine Toilette im Wagon?
Arthur Breslauer: Niemals.
David Boder: So, wie hat man dann die Bedürf..., die Bedürfnisse befriedigt?
Arthur Breslauer: Zeitweise ist, äh, ist der Zug, äh, stehen geblieben.
David Boder: Und die Kinder?
Arthur Breslauer: Die Kinder haben, äh, auch.
David Boder: Ja, ich meine, und wenn die zur Toilette gehen mussten?
Arthur Breslauer: Konnten sie nicht ihre Not verrichten.
David Boder: Nun?...Also?
Arthur Breslauer: Also haben sie geleidet, äh...gelitten.
David Boder: Haben sie nicht irgendwie probiert, das im Wagen zu tun?
Arthur Breslauer: Ich glaub, es ist vorgekommen, öfters, nicht wahr. Es war ausweichbar [Breslauer meint „unausweichbar“, nicht „ausweichbar“].
David Boder: Ja, und wie hat man das getan?
Arthur Breslauer: Vor den Leuten. Vor allen, ja.
David Boder: Ja. Also, äh, dann sind Sie in 11 Tagen, sind Sie nach Belsen-Belsen angekommen?
Arthur Breslauer: Bergen-Belsen
David Boder: Wollen Sie mir ein bisschen beschreiben, wie hat das ausgesehen, wenn Sie dort hingekommen sind?
Arthur Breslauer: Also, wir waren in einer sogenannten bevorzugten Gruppe.
David Boder: Ja.
Arthur Breslauer: Das bestand darin, dass wir nur die Hausarbeiten verrichteten, was wir, also, im Lager zu unserem Unterhalt...
David Boder: Nötig hatten.
Arthur Breslauer: Nötig hätten, haben.
David Boder: Hat man die Frauen und Kinder mit den Männern zusammen ge...?
Arthur Breslauer: Nein, die Frauen waren extra untergebracht, und die Männer auch.
David Boder: Mit wem waren Sie? Bloß die ungarische Gruppe?
Arthur Breslauer: Die ungarische Gruppe, worin auch viele Jugoslawen, auch Rumänen waren.
David Boder: Christen oder Juden?
Arthur Breslauer: Nur Juden.
David Boder: Nur Juden. Nun, zur Arbeit hat man Sie nicht genommen.
Arthur Breslauer: Nein.
David Boder: Wie hat man Sie gefüttert?
Arthur Breslauer: Wir haben die übliche Nahrung bekommen. Es war ein Eintopfgericht aus...
David Boder: Na?
Arthur Breslauer: Rüben.
David Boder: Ja.
Arthur Breslauer: Sehr selten waren Kartoffeln, Eine annehmbare Butterportion haben wir gehabt.
David Boder: Das war natürlich Margarine.
Arthur Breslauer: Auch, Margarine, gemischt, aber auch Butter
David Boder: Auch Butter, nun?
Arthur Breslauer: Und Brotportionen haben wir auch erhalten. Nur war das Brot sehr schlecht.
David Boder: Das war in welchem Jahr?
Arthur Breslauer: 1944
David Boder: Vierundvierzig. Welchen Monat ungefähr?
Arthur Breslauer: Am 30. Juni sind wir eingewagoniert worden, und am 18. August sind wir auf die Schweiz gekommen.
David Boder: Aha. Also das war der 30. Juni.
Arthur Breslauer: Ja.
David Boder: Da waren Sie von Juli bis August bloß dort, nicht wahr?
Arthur Breslauer: Vom Juli, vom 11. Juli bis 18. August.
David Boder: Nun, was war ja nicht lang. Fünf Wochen, sechs Wochen.
Arthur Breslauer: Ja, aber wir sind nur dreihundert Leute weggeschafft worden. Die übrigen sind dortgeblieben bis 7. Dezember.
David Boder: Nun?
Arthur Breslauer: Was? Und am 7. Dezember sind sie auch in die Schweiz geführt worden.
David Boder: Also, wollen wir dann weitergehen? Sie haben dann in Belsen-Belsen bloß gewartet. Und wieso ist Ihre Tochter krank geworden?
Arthur Breslauer: Sie hat Masern bekommen.
David Boder: Die ältere Tochter.
Arthur Breslauer: Die ältere Tochter.
David Boder: Nun, wo hat man sie dann, äh...
Arthur Breslauer: Und da, nachdem sie nicht, äh, verpflegt, äh, gepflegt werden konnte, hat, ist eine Komplikation eingetreten.
David Boder: Nun. Die Lungen.
Arthur Breslauer: Ungarn. Dort konnte man sie auch nicht heilen, so wie es nötig war. Die Nahrung konnte sie auch nicht bekommen, die sie, die einem schweren Kranken also verabreicht werden müsste.
David Boder: Ja.
Arthur Breslauer: So ist sie...
David Boder: War sie im Revier oder ist sie mit Ihnen im Block gewesen? Mit Ihrer Frau im Block gewesen?
Arthur Breslauer: Mit meiner Frau im Block.
David Boder: Sie ist im Block auch gestorben?
Arthur Breslauer: Ja.
David Boder: Hat man Ihnen erlaubt, sie zu bestatten?
Arthur Breslauer: Nein, man hat sie weggeführt. Wir haben sie nur bis zum Tor geführt.
David Boder: Nun? Und dann? Also im August?
David Boder: Also, im August? Was hat dann passiert? [Stille]
David Boder: Dann im August hat man sie nach der Schweiz geführt. Wie hat man das bekannt gemacht?
Arthur Breslauer: Ein Obergruppenführer ist gekommen und hat uns mitgeteilt, hat Auslese gemacht, wer mitkommen wird.
David Boder: Ja.
Arthur Breslauer: Und. Wir haben die Reise wieder in Viehwagone gemacht.
Arthur Breslauer: So wie nach, von Ungarn.
Arthur Breslauer: Man hat Ihnen aber mit der Familie zusammen geschickt?
Arthur Breslauer: Ja.
David Boder: Ja. Nun?
Arthur Breslauer: Dann sind wir im, am 21. August hier in Basel eingetroffen.
David Boder: Also können Sie mir das ein bissle erklären? Wir haben in Amerika, wenn ich Sie richtig verstehe, sehr wenig von dieser Gruppe gehört. Ich hab aber schon einen Jungen gehabt, einen Jungen, der hier im ORT studiert, äh, sein Vater ist auch hier im Lande, der mit solch einer Gruppe auch mitgegangen ist. Ich glaube es sind 25 Leute von irgendwo genommen worden. Und wurden dieser Gruppe angeschlossen. Wer hat das Ganze arrangiert?
Arthur Breslauer: Das hat die Zionist, äh, das haben die Zionisten arrangiert?
David Boder: Welche Zionisten?
Arthur Breslauer: Die Kolozsvár Zionisten haben das gemacht.
David Boder: Was ist die Kolozsvár?
Arthur Breslauer: Das ist die Hauptstadt von Siebenbürgen.
David Boder: Das ist wo?
Arthur Breslauer: Ungarn
David Boder: Oh! die Zionisten von Ungarn haben was getan?
Arthur Breslauer: Haben diese Gruppe, diese sogenannte Alia-[undeutlich; vielleicht: „Waren-Gruppe“].
David Boder: Oh! die Alía war das. Und die haben diese Gruppe zusammengeschickt?
Arthur Breslauer: Ja.
David Boder: War das meistens reiche Leute?
Arthur Breslauer: Nein. teilweise. Teilweise waren reiche Leute, die viel Geld gezahlt haben, um in diese Gruppe reinzukommen. Aber es waren, die meisten waren aber arme Leute.
David Boder: Was haben Sie bezahlen müssen?
Arthur Breslauer: Ich.... [unverständlich]
David Boder: Also, Sie haben aber bezahlt?
Arthur Breslauer: Ja.
David Boder: Wie für Ihre Familie.
Arthur Breslauer: [unverständlich]
David Boder: Also, und mit diesem Gelde konnte man auch andere, ärmere Leute, ohne zu bezahlen, mitnehmen. Naja. Und? Wie haben Sie das riskiert, den Deutschen das zu trauen?
Arthur Breslauer: Wir haben keinen anderen Ausweg gehabt.
David Boder: Aha.
Arthur Breslauer: Wir haben damit so gerechnet, dass wenn wir dort bleiben, werden wir hundert Prozent sicher....
David Boder: Vernichtet.
Arthur Breslauer: Vernichtet werden.
David Boder: Ja.
Arthur Breslauer: So haben wir kalkuliert, dass da doch zehn, zwanzig Prozent Chancen vorhanden sind...
David Boder: Hat man den Deutschen was dafür bezahlt? War das eine Bestechungsgeschichte, oder?
Arthur Breslauer: Das war eine Abmachung. Gegen Warenlieferung wurde diese Gruppe...
David Boder: Gegen was?
Arthur Breslauer: Gegen Waren, wurden mitgenommen.
David Boder: Ja.
Arthur Breslauer: Kriegswichtige Waren, nicht wahr? Aber die Einzelheiten weiß ich nicht.
David Boder: Ja. nun? Sagen Sie, wie haben sich die anderen Juden verhalten, dass solch eine spezielle Gruppe geformt, formiert wird?
Arthur Breslauer: Das war, diese Organisation war nicht so all bekannt. Und wie wir noch, bevor wir abgereist sind, war eine zweite Gruppe schon organisiert worden.
David Boder: Ja.
Arthur Breslauer: Mit dem Ziel weitere Leute...
David Boder: Menschen auf diese Weise rauszubekommen.
Arthur Breslauer: Rausbekommen.
David Boder: Ist was davon geworden?
Arthur Breslauer: Leider nicht.
David Boder: Also, Sie gingen raus, ungefähr dreihundert Personen. Die wurden...
Arthur Breslauer: Wo?
David Boder: Von Belsen-Belsen.
Arthur Breslauer: Ja.
David Boder: Sie wurden sozusagen in Viehwagonen geladen und wo hat man sie gebracht? Nach Basel?
Arthur Breslauer: Nach Basel.
David Boder: Wer hat Sie dann an der Grenze empfangen?
Arthur Breslauer: In der Schweiz hat uns die, äh, das Rote Kreuz empfangen.
David Boder: Die haben schon davon gewusst.
Arthur Breslauer: Davon, ja. Wir wurden avisiert.
David Boder: Also, wie weit sind die Deutschen mit Ihnen gegangen?
Arthur Breslauer: Bis zur, äh, Grenzstation.
David Boder: Hat man Sie dort verpediert [Unklar]?
Arthur Breslauer: Doch! Sehr streng.
David Boder: Wie?
Arthur Breslauer: Alles wurde dort durchgestöbert. Alles.
David Boder: Warum, was wollten die jetzt?
Arthur Breslauer: Papiere, Briefsachen, Bücher, Wertsachen wurden genommen?
David Boder: Was für Wertsachen hat man noch gehabt?
Arthur Breslauer: Einige hätten vielleicht doch etwas gerettet.
David Boder: Ja. Naja, und das hat man weggenommen? Und dann hat man was mit dem Zug gemacht?
Arthur Breslauer: Da hat man den Zug abgefertigt und über die Grenze gelassen.
David Boder: Die Lokomotive hat den...
Arthur Breslauer: Ja.
David Boder: Zug rübergezogen.
David Boder: Ja, nun? Und da war das Rote Kreuz schon auf der anderen Seite.
Arthur Breslauer: Dort wurden wir schon empfangen. Diese Glückseligkeit, die die Gruppe erlebt hat, ist unbeschreiblich!
David Boder: Ja.
Arthur Breslauer: Die Schweiz hat uns sehr schön empfangen, hat uns sofort...
David Boder: Ein bisschen lauter!
Arthur Breslauer: Hat uns sofort, nachher Suppe und Obst verabreicht, hat uns sofort in eine Badeanstalt gebracht. Nachher, untergebracht und nach drei Tagen sind wir verteilt worden. Wir sind nach Montreux gekommen.
David Boder: War die zionistische Organisation, die Vertreter dort?
Arthur Breslauer: Nur diese, die mit uns gekommen sind.
David Boder: Nur die, die mit Ihnen gekommen sind.
Arthur Breslauer: Ja.
David Boder: Also da haben keine Zionisten Sie von der Schweiz...
Arthur Breslauer: Nein, dort haben sie uns noch nicht empfangen.
David Boder: Nun?
Arthur Breslauer: Nur später sind die Gruppenführer mit den Organisationen in Verbindung getreten.
David Boder: Ja. Also, Sie haben es eigentlich nicht sehr schlecht in Belsen-Belsen gehabt, außer dem Unglücksfall mit Ihrer Tochter. Persönlich, wie hat man Sie behandelt?
Arthur Breslauer: Oh! Streng hat man uns behandelt.
David Boder: Waren da selten Schlägereien bei Ihnen?
Arthur Breslauer: Schlägereien waren bei uns, bei unserer Gruppe nicht, äh, nicht. Nebenan haben wir mit angesehen, wie man die Leute geschlagen hat. Das waren Juden aus Holland.
David Boder: Aus Holland?
Arthur Breslauer: Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Arthur Breslauer: Die wurden, die haben schwere Arbeit...
David Boder: Geleistet.
Arthur Breslauer: Verrichtet.
David Boder: Hmm.
Arthur Breslauer: Und waren sehr misshandelt worden.
David Boder: Nun? Aber in ihrem Block ist das nicht passiert?
Arthur Breslauer: Nein.
David Boder: Und der Blockälteste war der von Ihnen gewählt oder von den?
Arthur Breslauer: Ja, der sogenannte Judenälteste
David Boder: Ja.
Arthur Breslauer: War von uns.
David Boder: Nun? Und was hat dann in der Schweiz passiert? Was haben Sie dann getan?
Arthur Breslauer: Dann sind wir in eine Auffangsaal gekommen und von dort nach sechs Wochen Aufenthalt in ein Heim...
David Boder: Ja.
Arthur Breslauer: Geführt worden und hier bin ich seit sechs Monaten und mache die Stickereikurs.
David Boder: Ah! Sie wohnen hier seit sechs Monaten und wieso [unverständlich]
Arthur Breslauer: Ja.
David Boder: [unverständlich] Nun sagen Sie, Sie waren ein Kaufmann bevor.
David Boder: Hatten Sie keine Ideen, wieder zu selben Beruf zurück zukommen?
Arthur Breslauer: Also, wenn ich Gelegenheit hätte, nach Amerika auszuwandern, auswandern zu können, dann könnte ich schon mich betätigen.
David Boder: Haben Sie Verwandte dort?
Arthur Breslauer: Leider haben wir keine Verwandten, nur Bekannte. Mein gottseliger Schwiegervater war ein sehr berühmter Gelehrte.
David Boder: Wo?
Arthur Breslauer: In Ungarn. Und der ist in Amerika sehr bekannt, und sehr angesehen und auch sehr geschätzt.
David Boder: Also haben Sie doch Verwandte!
Arthur Breslauer: Verwandte nicht, nur Bekannte, und äh.
David Boder: Also der Schwiegervater ist schon tot.
Arthur Breslauer: Tot, seit 10 Jahren
David Boder: Oh! nun? Und also was ist Ihr Plan, nachdem Sie das Geschäft gelernt haben. Was wollen Sie tun?
Arthur Breslauer: Entweder nach Erez, oder...
David Boder: Also nach Israel.
Arthur Breslauer: Ja, oder was ich lieber möchte, nach Amerika, nachdem ich also in Amerika größere Chancen hätte. Ich bin doch ein erfahrener Kaufmann und erfahrener Börsenmann.
David Boder: Haben Sie Südamerika, an Südamerika nicht gedacht?
Arthur Breslauer: Notfalls, ist nicht ausgeschlossen.
David Boder: Denn sehen Sie mal, in Amerika möchte man nicht gerne die, ich glaube wenigstens, nicht so gerne die Kaufleute sofort haben, aber in Südamerika haben die meisten, die Handwerker, die nachher Kaufleute geworden sind, sich sehr gut etabliert.
Arthur Breslauer: Doch, nachdem ich mich umgeschult habe, betrachte ich mich nicht nur als Kaufmann, sondern als Handwerker, auch. Und ich könnte mich sehr schön mit meinem neuen Beruf erhalten.
David Boder: Und was tut Ihre Frau?
Arthur Breslauer: [unverständlich].
David Boder: Ihre Frau, ihre Frau hat dieselbe Arbeit?
Arthur Breslauer: Meine Frau hat sich auch umschulen lassen.
David Boder: Ist sie jetzt hier?
Arthur Breslauer: Leider nein, sie ist bei den Kindern?
David Boder: Wo ist das Kind? Auf dem Lande?
Arthur Breslauer: Ja.